kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are getting ready to say i do that could
be
really cute a few months into their
engagement e.t has new details about the
couple's wedding planning a source tells
e.t quote courtney and travis want to
get married sooner than later wedding
planning has already begun and things
are in motion they want their wedding to
be really exclusive they both have a lot
of friends but want it to be intimate
and special all sorts of stuff good a
lot of surprises the source adds quote
both courtney and travis are so looking
forward to spending the rest of their
lives together as soul mates
and both stars are quote very involved
in the wedding planning process and the
wedding will be very quote them and
their style meanwhile courtney's ex
scott disick apparently isn't too happy
about the engagement the source also
says quote scott is not thrilled about
the idea of courtney and travis getting
married and is still processing it
i mean i think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day however the
source notes quote courtney and scott
have been getting along just fine there
is no bad blood and balancing time with
the kids has never been a huge issue for
them
the musician popped the question to the
reality star back in
october what is happening here court
shared this snap of the romantic moment
to instagram alongside the caption quote
forever a source told e.t at the time
quote travis walked courtney to an area
on the beach that had candles and red
roses in the shape of a heart it was
very romantic and the couple is over the
moon sister kim kardashian posted this
clip of the love birds kissing at their
engagement dinner putting courtney's new
ring on full display the couple began
dating in january of 2021 following
years of being long time friends and
neighbors it's pretty cool yeah
throughout the holidays the couple
wasn't shy about sharing their precious
moments
for halloween courtney and travis nailed
in edward scissorhands inspired couples
costume and they later made christmas
time a family affair disneyland is the
best place on earth courtney shared
these photos from their festive day at
disneyland and no surprise here courtney
and travis rang in the new year together
snuggled up on the couch plus travis
even found himself on tick-tock with
courtney and her nine-year-old daughter
penelope it's dr dre's dead he's locked
in my basement
i'm sick of him look at him walking
around rapping
back in november he volunteered for this
fun dance collab
[Music]
you